khloe kardashian just got the internet
talking with one
eye-catching accessory i love it
on sunday the 36-year-old reality star
took to instagram to share
this racy photo of her good american
shoe line
but it didn't take long for fans to
point out that she was sporting a
massive diamond on her ring finger it's
a beautiful thing morgan stewart swooped
into the comments to ask what
literally all of us were thinking quote
are they
to which coco replied quote yep they are
um they are like the shoes or
they are like you're telling us you're
engaged it would be amazing
we agree either way amazing but shortly
after that chloe clarified writing my
reply was to the question
are they my reply is yep they are
meaning yes the shoes are dropping on
225.
i'm gonna figure it all out i promise
you chloe playfully reacted to friends
and fans commenting on both her awesome
bod
and the quote ice rink on her finger but
she didn't comment directly when
asked if the photo was her way of
announcing an engagement
then there was the keeping up with the
kardashians star's boyfriend tristan
thompson
who hilariously responded to the pick
writing
wow that grass is cut to perfection
isn't that crazy
chloe and tristan who share a
two-year-old daughter true rekindled
their romance last august following a
year-long split
a source previously told et that chloe
has forgiven the nba star of his past
cheating scandals adding quote they are
back to being committed
are still in love and giving their
relationship another chance
and hoping that it will succeed this
time around
and fans can watch their love journey
and their talk of having another baby
together when the 20th and final season
of keeping up with the kardashians
premieres march 18th
on e i don't know true's getting older
and i just feel like it's now time
to have another kid yup
i like to hear
you